Yeah
[inaudible] I want to do the same thing.
Somebody else,
basically the next generation is going through a smooth experience,
a fast that growth
[inaudible].
Okay.
This is a quick recap here of where we'd done last 20 years.
And,
uh,
as bill said,
um,
it's been,
it's been quite a journey.
It started 20 years ago.
We've,
um,
a dramatic event in my family when my sister was 22 years old at the time,
uh,
died and,
she passed away,
um,
and um,
in conditions that were pretty tough because our,
her heart,
her heart failed and she was pretty upset at what was going on in the world and
she was trying to make a difference.
So a couple of,
a couple of weeks later,
we discovered her writings that she had left behind.
And,
um,
there was a project there that,
uh,
was basically encouraging people to invest in other people.
And I took this project and,
um,
I,
uh,
implemented what was my passion at the time,
was basketball into the project and um,
founded giving back in a,
in with a model that was,
uh,
my mom's Modo.
Every time I was,
uh,
going through the front door,
she kept saying and never forget where you come from.
And,
uh,
that,
um,
started a whole movement,
a global movement in which,
uh,
I went on and try to help kids from all around the world,
um,
to get scholarships,
proof sports,
uh,
basketball and education and,
um,
to also have the moral that they will never forget where they come from and I
will come back to their communities at some point and give back.
And,
um,
so that led me here in the United States,
in the beautiful city of Newark,
New Jersey and I where we set up the first basketball camps there and whatever
we call social business now we're doing at the time already.
And,
um,
it gave a lot of exporter to these kids and,
some of them are here right now.
And I gave him a lot of opportunities,
uh,
to go through their studies and,
become,
um,
uh,
go through a different path than what they were supposed to be.
So these kids came from France,
but also,
um,
Senegal and Mali.
Uh,
but cannot find.
So,
um,
Nigeria a little bit everywhere.
And,
uh,
we let her set on,
set up a academies,
um,
in a,
in Africa of sports leadership and social leadership at the same time.
And,
um,
the whole story here is really about the power of giving back.
We think that giving is a wonderful act and just an amazing act and we just feel
that it's not a complete act.
Uh,
when you give a,
you,
you fix situations and um,
and you probably heal and put a bandaid.
Um,
but we think that with the act of giving back,
we can really put the person into a position to come back and empower other
people and keep the chain of life.
And,
um,
and that's really our sustainable way for us to,
uh,
to,
to build any,
any social business.
And,
um,
we never received any grants and we were able to put this all together because
we have our alumni that,
that came back to the program and,
or able to help.
So some of them are here.
And,
um,
I'm going to invite a Cujo Godsey here who was a,
one of the first,
uh,
student athletes to come to the United States.
And I had a quite a journey,
uh,
coming from,
some of the toughest areas in,
in,
in France,
and,
uh,
going all the way and working in Wall Street.
Kudrow okay,
thanks.
Bye.
The car.
Uh,
thanks for,
uh,
allowing us to be here today.
It's a pleasure for us,
all of us to be at Google and to share our stories and for being part of the,
uh,
giving back,
um,
group.
Um,
and program is just a privileged bubble car.
Uh,
as Bible car said,
I'm from Paris.
Um,
I came to the states about 20 years ago.
I actually Babka recruited me to play basketball from,
um,
from the streets of Paris and to allow me to come here to states and,
uh,
in play high school basketball.
Um,
and from high school I ended up going to college for four years and playing
division one at Fairfield.
Um,
I've been very,
very fortunate,
uh,
because,
um,
I,
I've,
I'm,
I'm coming from a very area outside of Paris.
It's a small town with a,
it was majority low income and minority groups and families.
And,
um,
before I came to the states,
uh,
education,
it was never a big part of what I believed in.
I think,
um,
there's always,
you've always been in a class where it is or does an athlete and a who doesn't
work and doesn't do his homework.
What I was me,
uh,
I've only been the wine,
I sort of,
uh,
put school to the side and,
becoming to the states of,
allow me to,
to,
uh,
you know,
to disregard that and to focus on,
on education.
And so to understand the value of education.
Um,
I was fortunate enough to,
uh,
to get a four year degree at a school in Connecticut.
Uh,
from there,
uh,
I've tried to play overseas,
um,
in France,
actually professional.
He didn't work out.
I came back to the states,
went back to New York City and a aid,
um,
and worked at a hedge fund.
Um,
and,
um,
I was there for eight years.
I,
in the meantime,
um,
I received an MBA,
so I was going to school part time,
went to school,
uh,
while I was working.
Uh,
and um,
now I'm,
I'm,
I'm actually studying for a Ford y'all side to go to law school.
Um,
and why Bob Carr I mentioned earlier is that it's one thing,
but education is something that you can carry with you all the time and no one
can take away from you.
And he has my dream.
Ultimately he was to come to the states and play in the NBA,
but things happen and I wasn't able to,
but was able to sort of take on the next step of my life and do something else
to education if through work.
Um,
and my journey is not,
he's not over obviously,
and I'm even looking to go to,
to laws,
got graduate when I've,
I'll be 40 years up every beat of the oldest law students at the school I go to.
Um,
but I think it's just one to,
one of the thing that Anesa Mandela said,
the quote is,
education is the most powerful weapon for change.
And I think this is why we're trying to provide here.
I gave him back his two to give hope to people that whether it's through sports
or through education,
they can make something of themselves and it,
he can change the world.
And what I'm wanting to do and what we're trying to do is to change people's
lives and I want to be a role model for them,
um,
of a mass standpoint.
So,
so yeah.
Thank you.
Kojo um,
Cujo is one of the,
uh,
hundreds of kids that received a scholarship to come to the United States and
took advantage of it.
Uh,
we,
we've had a lot of basketball success stories,
but,
uh,
he stories one of the biggest success story of all because he was able to
capitalize on the education and a and be who he is right now.
So,
um,
that's,
that's also something that we always try to push is,
is to understand that the more we're going to empower people with the education
and the more there'll be inclined to also give back and to know how give back to
their communities.
And,
um,
in that regard,
I'm going to introduce,
uh,
Gershwin yabbies La from the Boston Celtics,
um,
who,
who also has a pretty unbelievable path that led him not only to the,
to the NBA,
but also to be our president for the organization here and be a social leader.
Gershwin is yours.
So first of all,
I want to say thank you for having us today.
It's really important for us and it means a lot.
So my name is Gershwin,
your [inaudible].
I'm a Boston Celtics player,
the best team of the NBA obviously.
But,
um,
today I've,
really try to,
to share part of my story with you.
So I grew up in a France,
a little city nearby Paris.
Um,
I always been playing basketball there and then moved to a few of the city in
France to play basketball.
And I'm me in every team that I play.
I'll never be the best player of my team.
I,
uh,
been underestimated a hold on my career,
but,
um,
one day Borkhar gave me call and uh,
him and the association really believe in me and the have me through my process.
Uh,
since this day,
uh,
we always be on the phone and he's talking.
And then one day I had the chance to go to hell a and a play against the best
players in the country.
And this experience for me is being a big,
big,
um,
part of me being here today cause I had to play against the best player a Honda
stand,
her life is.
And uh,
I understand the change that I got to play basketball then he was really a gift
from me.
So as soon as I get back from,
uh,
this trip,
everything changed in my life.
Uh,
I just understand the things more,
uh,
was thankful for everything.
And,
uh,
since this day Barbara Crane me out a great contact.
Uh,
cause I'm from France and where I grew up,
I grew up in a big family.
Uh,
we sometime we have,
uh,
less,
so it was really difficult for me.
I grew up with something my friend,
uh,
they fail,
some of them went to jail.
So for me,
uh,
at this point being thankful,
it was just something that I was dreaming,
but something that I in my head every day.
Uh,
he just started being a mission for me and helping the people give back to the
communities.
I mean a lot.
And this project for us is really just something big.
Uh,
we,
the young talent and leaders and such was going to explain us a little bit more
about her story.
But,
uh,
this project really means a lot for us.
Uh,
like I said,
the mission is in her head,
but also in our life.
Um,
that's what we're going through.
Everything.
My dream came true and coming to the MBA association did a lot for me,
for me and my family.
And,
uh,
today I can really say that basketball saved my life have made through
everything and I'm really thankful for that.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Gretchen.
Um,
as you see,
um,
uh,
Gershwin and Kudo here represent well the,
the ecosystem of giving back and,
uh,
as far as,
as a young student,
athletes that were empowered a fru for the endeavors and,
uh,
that also were able to overcome their,
they own problems.
And,
uh,
we,
we see a lot of,
uh,
problems all around the world and,
and we think it's always with,
uh,
the powerful,
the has to come back,
come to the power less and find a solution.
But,
uh,
we,
we know that,
uh,
in those,
in industry rough neighborhoods,
um,
uh,
there's,
there's a lot of kids that have a lot of talents and,
uh,
if,
if they're given a chance to bring their talent up in whatever it is,
they,
they can change the world because they can grow up with that mission to come
back to the communities and change it.
Um,
as,
uh,
Gershwin measured.
I mentioned.
Um,
right now we're trying to to scale the system.
Uh,
this giving back system and the best way that we found is a tool to put our
efforts into young women,
especially young women right now in west Africa and a,
I'm going to introduce a video right now that's going to tell you the story of
Amsa to job who was right here and a WHO's part of our program now
growing up in Italy,
I understood the word privilege when spending summertime in my beautiful native
Senegal and seeing a lot of my girls beers,
having no access to education and no skill that who allow them to enjoy a
dignified basic life.
Michael's in Binta is one of the 7 million woman who social faith is doomed to
fail before they life even start.
I had to find a way to break the cycle.
[inaudible] was all I had a scholastic education,
access to global culture and thinking and more importantly,
a loving and caring single mother that gave me more than I ever needed.
Yeah.
I realize how much some of our dysfunctional local resources had to offer.
I went on collecting and recycling the small wasted piece of African craft that
our hundred thousand woken pillows throw away every day.
And I created a sustainable interior design.
Brand name Wolof
dual solution is accessible by any group who is a willing learner as it takes is
20 cents the cost of a thread and a needle to come and acquire the basics at my
feet of charter workshops.
Open it to young girls that have no access to education.
My vision is to sell Wolof globally and disrupt the interior design industry by
giving a voice to the voiceless.
And yet so elegant and powerful women of Africa.
Soon enough,
Wolof,
we'd be able to tell the board a new set of inspiring deals of the hardworking
was Indian creative and traditional African woman.
This community will keep growing as the girl we empowered today will mentor the
next generation of interior designers.
They will be able to enjoy a sustainable living bread,
the cycle of illiteracy and will become role models of their daughters.
Dislike.
My mother has been for me all my life.
Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for having us here today.
Um,
as you saw,
I am the proud founder of Wolof,
but also I am the mentor of,
uh,
the Grill Academy,
one of the first mentors.
So I've been,
I've been on the program for the past few months and for those past few months,
there have been two words that have stuck with me and have been my mantra.
So those words are embrace yourself.
A lot of people ask me why I choose those two words because they've also been my
Instagram Hashtag for every feature that I've posted.
But those two words,
because for the past few months,
I have been embracing every single fiber of myself.
I've been embracing my fears,
my flaws,
my weaknesses.
But mostly I've been aware of what is surrounding me.
And as a mentor for the next generation of the grower academy,
I want to pass all this feeling to these girls because I want them to be
fearless,
to be powerful.
But mostly I want them to believe in themselves because we live in a society
where everything they tell us every day is,
you can't make it.
And my question is always,
why?
It's because you're a woman and want them to actually believe that they can if
they put their mindset into it.
That's why I created the groove academy and it's not like any other academy
because we use tools,
ours,
virtual reality,
video games,
chess,
coding,
programming,
boxing.
Because we want these girls to be challenged every and we want them to believe
that if you put your mindset into something,
you can make it.
We have to break all the obstacles that are in your way in order to do that,
and as you know,
the [inaudible] Academy's going to use the same ecosystem as giving back,
meaning that the girls that we empowered today,
we'll come back as mentor for the next generation,
but we're not like the man's here.
It's not going to take us 10 years to do that.
It took,
you can take us,
we want these girls to be able to do that within three months and having done
this program for a week before coming here,
I can assure you that I did.
These girls are able to give back within two weeks,
within a week.
They're able to teach others what they've learned within a week.
They appropriated the program for themselves and for me that is incredible
because I now can see all the work that has been done by giving back in,
by grow now that it's actually is possible because some of them we went to the
giving back day where they dug all of these girls that don't have access to
education,
how to play video games and those girls that same day we're able to help.
There are others school,
the other girls that are there how to play video games and they never been to
school.
They don't know what his football or how to play with cars.
So I can assure you that this program is amazing and I'm really thankful to be
here today and to speak for these girls and also to speak for myself for my
story and also for giving back in the groove academy.
Thank you.
[inaudible] we are,
we actually have a little video rather grow academy.
All right.
Where are you going to see those girls in action?
I wanted to use my passion and my passion is fashion to give people happiness as
I am now a matter of the next generation.
The Royal Academy,
something caught me.
It was the motto of giving by was never forget where you come from.
That's how real is.
So it's been on the transmission and the real investing in the program decided
to focus on women because we know that women are the future one advances.
We all advance when one succeeds or knows how to,
you know,
solve a problem.
We help to bring the other girl up along with her.
Nobody gets left behind.
And the Grill Academy,
uh,
let's see,
I liquid
capacity.
So kindof it
approval
the girl academy.
Not only do we believe in you,
but we want you to also believe in yourself.
Like it's not,
it's never easy.
It's never going to be an easy journey.
Sometimes you'll fall,
sometimes you'll feel so good about yourself and sometimes it'll knock you right
back down.
But the point of it all is that you get up,
brush off the
dirt,
and then we get back right on it.
And,
you know,
become champions,
become who we truly are.
[inaudible]
okay.
Well English.
Okay.
Good morning.
Thanks.
[inaudible].
Don't
even like days.
Okay.
Um,
so this is,
this was,
uh,
the,
the last video here that we're going to show,
but,
uh,
before we,
we go for the Q and a.
Um,
just,
uh,
this,
this experience with the,
uh,
with the girl academy has been transforming the whole organization really
because we came to the realization that to,
in order to be able to get a powerful social entrepreneurs,
it's not just about,
uh,
going on to a path,
a set path like,
hey,
here's your mission.
Your vision here is what you gotta do.
But it's also about revealing the best in us wherever he is,
the self confidence,
the ability to transmit the messages to the next generation,
uh,
their ability to listen,
to be,
to have collaborative work.
So that's what those girls have been doing.
And I'm sad to has been a terrific mentor for all those girls.
And all those girls that you see here are going to be the mentor to the next
generation as well.
And that's how we are building this community.
And we think that if every community can be built that way,
every social business can be built that way,
then that's the answer to be sustainable and to be able to defeat the problems
of the poverty.
So thank you everybody for coming.
Thank you for having us again.
Thank you.
I just wanted to ask a couple questions to wrap up here.
Um,
first you mentioned giving back days.
Do you want to explain to us a little bit more about how they work and what your
plans are for the future for that?
So the giving back days are,
um,
Nah,
days of happiness that we give to,
uh,
kids usually have,
people from a vulnerable groups.
Um,
and that,
uh,
what we want in those in those in those days is to be able to reproduce what we
do at the Royal Academy.
Meaning really give him confidence into what they're doing and show him the path
of giving back in one day.
And we do that in a fun way,
but also it's a,
it's a,
it's a platform for all of us to be able to go back and give.
And that's one thing that is very important now.
Our system is that ecosystem that we put together.
The were every,
everybody can come in and be a part of it.
And uh,
and so that's the giving back days and it's been very successful because we've
been able to,
to touch a lot of young people through that program.
Um,
thank you Baba car.
Next,
uh,
for those of us in the audience that would like to get involved,
what are some of the ways that we could help out giving back and grow academy?
Well,
um,
come,
come over to synagogue.
Uh,
uh,
you see it's a beautiful countries,
sunny and uh,
and more importantly,
a,
those girls can really benefit from the experiences of everybody.
Uh,
again,
we,
we talk about mentorship.
Uh,
there is no professors,
there is no traditional teacher in our academy and these are college girls.
Um,
but I think they really enjoy,
uh,
having expertise and experience from all over the world.
So that would be the first thing.
The other thing is that we always trying to research a new ways to,
to problem solve.
Um,
you saw that lab that we put together with all those different tools.
and if you have any ideas,
if you want to be part of that,
please let us know.
And uh,
and the last thing is that those girls have um,
they put together all day at work.
They organized their work into a Google drive,
Google docs and a,
and they share it.
Uh,
so they have self evaluation,
um,
uh,
within themselves.
But also we invite anybody that could,
that would want to be a mentor,
um,
and not being able to come all the way there to also be,
be able to do it that way so that a girl could share,
for example,
her work with you.
Well,
on behalf of Google,
thank you very much for coming,
Bubba Karger.
Sean,
I'm so too,
and Cujo we really enjoyed hearing from you and,
and appreciate the great work that you're doing for your communities.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.